Samuel leaves here and today I have the
keys to the castle man that was a
stressful few weeks and I just wanted to
take a minute on this video there's many
people I could thank and part of my code
of honor is to recognize people have
helped me and to honor people and
they've been so many people but in this
video I wanted to honor my lawyer mr.
Sam Hawking if it wasn't for him I
probably would not have been able to
complete on time for the property and he
saved me a fortune on stamp duty so I'm
gonna be picking his brain on this video
take good notes I've seen a sec Sam who
leaves here and I have with me the man
himself mr. Sam Hawking great turn on
the show thank you very much Simon oh
thanks the invite it's very very welcome
and you are the person who is
responsible for me getting the keys to
my castle just yesterday I think that
wasn't just them to me but I'm glad to
be part of that so yeah it was fantastic
and Sam you managed to save me how much
money on stamp duty like 40,000 pound
more than 40,000 pounds damage you say
completely got even push through really
quickly despite all the hurdles you're
also an expert in lease option agreement
right yes so you've done these option
agreements for many of my students and
they've just done a couple for Alastair
which is really great so if it's okay
I'll just be asking you some questions
picking your brain yeah and I know
they're not really prepared anything but
be really good to just tap into
someone's brain like yours a solicitor
expert in property that's that's that's
doing weird and marvelous things so he's
okay that's fine all right tell us how
we first met I think we met through the
client introduction I said what about
networking event at first I think you're
right yeah we met a network networking
event
I was vegan you were speaking and you
were speaking on that the charity the
charity work we do in Africa yes
and I'm very passionate about giving
back to community as well and that's
something that I would like to support
yeah I was intending to do it already as
you know well you all very welcome to
come out to Uganda or Zambia with us one
of the years that I'm certainly going to
say and I never bring my family as well
really I want my girls to experience
that giving back
yes philosophy I've done quite well for
myself in property generally outside the
legal firm as well as the legal firm
yeah and I don't want my girls just to
be handed everything on a great they've
got to learn the true value of life of
community and not not to think that they
can put their feet up yeah I think with
with Wealth's and with with when you've
given a lot you have a lot of
responsibility true and then and they
need to understand that that's brilliant
absolutely fantastic so you have success
in property both as an investor and as a
law practice is that right absolutely so
tell me a little about your own personal
investments then what is it that you've
been buying so I set out my property
goals and I was 16 and then I spoke to a
financial advisor that I trusted he was
quite a bit older than me at the end is
rugby career I was at the start of mine
and he actually told me I don't know
anyone that makes proper money out of
property don't bother and that sort of
stunted me a little but I started buying
a single net didn't bite that many I got
involve the wrong partner the wrong
partner as in a partner that said he
wanted to do the same things as me
who appeared to have all the right
experience and but is his risk profile
and his his action didn't match his
words so I didn't get so far but the
market went up this was sort of early
90s so did quite well I I've always
bought on the return on the yield and
when the prices went up
doubled and tripled the yield haft and
and and went down by two-thirds huh so
so where I decided to sell quite a most
of what I had only kept three properties
but you made a lot of profit doing that
made a lot of profit I paid off on my
debt and then I set up the legal
practice and it was the it was the
income from those properties that
sustained me when I couldn't take any
money from the legal firm in the first
year of practice and again my third year
of practice as the recession came in
with a rather large bump and then then I
raised equity by then I'd already got
quite a few investor clients and small
developers so I had already got a lot of
property experience practically but
married young building work did building
work to finance my study in university
and my wife's so when I then refinance
the properties that had paid off the
mortgages and lent the money to my
developer clients who the banks had
pulled their finance so I did quite well
doing that and then the prices came down
to a level where the returns are right
again so I made I set myself a goal to
buy to buy a large portfolio on my own
this time without the partner that sort
of held me back the previous time
however by then I'd got a very busy law
practice and when I've got a goal I
absolutely intend to achieve it
trouble was without time and and without
having haven't having had my fingers
burnt with a part no not having a
partner ready to go I was doing on my
own so I would find properties perhaps I
would set aside an hour to source the
right properties and I think right where
to do those viewings and some of those
happen to be auction properties so three
weeks out had found them these are
perfect
two weeks and six days later I'm
thinking right I must go and see those
properties but I've got appointments now
what am I going to do about it realize
the auctions the next day so I do I
absolutely tell my clients not to do but
I wasn't going to let my goals go I I
would I would carry out the due
diligence that I could in the time make
some five pocket estimates and bid at
the auction and I've got six buildings
like that for the flats and if you've
got the right relationships I had very
good relationships with the auctioneer
and the auctioneer in South Wales for
Paul wash and with seal & Co and I
bought properties in the London auctions
where either invest the clients have
viewed them and told me about them and
then they said right actually can't get
the funds together it's too big for me
or whatever and so I was in the position
then to go and buy even though hadn't
seen it I've got I was satisfied that
I'd done enough due diligence to take
the chance and so now I've got about 50
flats in buildings Lots them they've got
commercial elements to them what about
ten single debts and some commercial
property and they're all my keepers I I
do quite a lot of networking I've been a
member of the BNI yeah and many with
that being a member of B and I for 11
years and what someone wanted to get
into property and he used to go along to
one of the National networking groups
and someone from Birmingham told him
that he should link up with mica and the
news from South Wales and so he actually
joined my BNI to to sort of regularly
meet up with me and we had read about
very strong relationship so
and have gone more into development we
actually set up a letting agency
together as well so we manage about
hundred twenty properties but we're just
merging it into a bigger entity because
we weren't satisfied with a manager and
that we weren't satisfied by that with a
way that it was progressing
it wasn't growing and if it's not
growing it's not exciting yeah a real
vast experience of property then between
law practice letting agent development
property investing so the development
we're doing now we just we have we've
almost finished a public conversion
we've got two flats left to convert
you've already done seven and a
prominent commercial property and just
finished off another three commercial
properties with seven flats above that
one as well and we've just started eight
new build bungalows we're about to start
ten new build houses we completed today
on eleven eleven studio flats you're a
dark horse am hoping that's brilliant I
didn't know what's the extent of your of
your portfolio and we've got six sites
that we're expected to complete on in
the next short while the congratulations
in process so it's when we know we're
doing the right thing we go for it yes I
think it's really funny because you
appear quite reserved in cool calm
collected but you're an absolute action
type in a real deal have you think
that's hidden that's part of your
success yeah it has to be I'm a doer and
so I very quickly get myself stuck in
what I'm doing I feel an obligation it's
within me to work hard it was brought up
as a farmer working all hours working
physically hard and there's something
within me that needs to do that and so
but I'm also recognized the fact that
when you do that you don't get very far
and so I'm continuously looking at ways
to our flowed things that I do and to
bring in people to help with things
we've got a great team and
a great team but I will always go and
find the next thing as well and fill up
my time and so I have to be careful how
I use my time so weekend's as we've
talked about weekend's I really try and
keep for my family and and and any
competitions that I do physical
competitions and during the week it's
all about work and and just doing enough
training to keep myself mentally sound
and in shape so Sam you're a property
investor property developer you've got a
law practice you've done lease option
agreement you've got a lot of experience
where do you think the housing market in
the UK is generally going over the next
sort of 10 years or so and is there
anything else that you do or you
involved with um well funny enough to
say that I actually studied financial
economics in university and I decided
that I was going to become a lawyer
property lawyer whilst I study my
Master's so I did my masters on the
ripple effect and did a lot of analysis
of all the data that we've got in the
country of house prices which was quite
interesting thing the obviously over
time property prices go up in certain
areas property prices step quite quite a
lot and so where there's been a plateau
for a while all of a sudden they'll
shoot up there's a lot of uncertainty at
the moment with brexit but I think so
far brexit hasn't been that bad and I
think that I don't think it is going to
be that bad
prices have gone above where they were
at the start when the recession came in
last time but they're not vastly more in
most places she's done things a little
different yeah cause that but you know
we're not in London I'm not in London
and yes I I'm I'm positive about the
property market I'd like to see the
government change what they've done to
the investor
proposition in other words the inability
to offset all of your interest against
tax yeah but from a personal perspective
all that has increased my business with
investors because of the strategies that
we use whereas people doing sort of
straightforward by - that work will have
noticed a rather large
fall in their in their work in terms of
other work that I do other things I'm
involved with in property I'm also a
board member of the Society for the
profession so very much
helping the profession making sure the
professions got a voice and also on the
board member of the policy and strategy
for the conveyancing Association which
has got all major conveyancers as
members member firms and are working
alongside the government to try and
change the way that we do conveyancing
to improve it to speed it up to provide
more certainty to stop because umping to
give more confidence to people that are
buying and selling that it is going to
happen and and also part of the part of
the leasehold issues in the press
recently very much involved in working
the government to make those changes and
speeding up early so we sold
transactions in stopping freeholders
take advantage of these people people
only sold properties stopping developers
selling lease old houses so tell us a
little about how did you manage to save
me so much money on the castle which
strategy firstly what do you think of
the castle I love it now I really like
property but I don't just really like
prime I don't I don't particularly love
some of the properties that I own the
sort of property that I really love is
seeing the property that you just bought
and seeing it transformed
back to its former glory and become
useful yeah and to have longevity you
leave your leaving a legacy your
reestablishing somebody else's legacy
and putting your own mark on it as well
I think it's absolutely fantastic and
I've done a few projects like that
myself not quite as grand as yours I've
been frustrated by it by one certainly
and I bought a really nice listed
building school in Mid Wales and was
really frustrated when we just lost
heart with it when we when they would
allow us to do what we wanted to do with
it yeah that's the problem of brand-new
star and yeah and all this and so they
come with their issues but I think the
way what you've already got is already
converted into the sort of units that
will give it longevity yeah
and so you haven't got to change the use
you've simply got to it's already got
prizes yes so you're three quarters of
the way there yeah and and and and and
that's really good yeah and so I'm
really looking forward to seeing and
where it when it when the work get done
you're very welcome to come out we were
gonna pay 50 old thousand pounds on
stamp duty then but then I was talking
with Russell and we said well if you buy
more than I think it's more than six
hours at once yeah if you want more six
houses at once you don't pay staff as we
pay very smooth about some juices that's
right not exactly in format yes so if
you like by more than six properties you
can pay six residential properties you
can choose to pay commercial stamp duty
rates now commercial stamp duty rates
are lower than the individual
residential purchase rates with the
additional 3% however when you're buying
more than one dwelling you can claim
multiple dwelling relief so if you're
buying two dwellings then you could then
then you can claim multiple dwelling
grief and no they didn't claim to
understand all this completely because
they are difficult right so the fact
that you are buying eight flats and two
the cottages you're buying ten dwellings
so you are paying 800,000 the average
cost of each dwelling was 80,000 pounds
and so we were able to claim multiple
dwelling relief and pay stamp duty based
on the multi multiple dwelling relief
raped yeah but that's the kind of thing
that could easily get missed up or
missed missed by alot of solicitors
right a lot of solicitors don't know
about the exemptions and the reliefs
they don't know how to apply them
there's a misconception that multiple
dwelling relief can only be used if each
unit each dwelling has its own separate
title yeah yeah most with reading relief
applies if it is a dwelling it doesn't
it doesn't need a legal title to make it
a dwelling a dwelling is a dwelling yeah
dwelling is somewhere where someone
lives it's not about whether it's
registered at Land Registry or not I
guess it just goes to show the
importance of having a good Power Team
and good people in eating because I
don't I don't know all this is it's
complex stuff right it is it's really
the rules are always changing the rules
they change the rules on this just
though was it was it may this year they
changed they changed the rules a few
years ago but they did they keep they've
updated their guidance recently they
updated their guidance in April on
multiple dwellings relief and there is
some conflicting guidance from the
revenue yeah and when is conflicting
guidance then it's important that you
know which guidance to follow yeah
and obviously we act in the clients best
interest so we generally follow what
works best to the client while I'm
grateful for that but but we will advise
the client when there is conflict yeah
where there is conflicting guidance and
then the client can make that choice and
make sure the client has got the the
defense for why we chose that route and
the guidance that we followed in
choosing that route should that should
the stamp duty return never be
questioned yeah that's great sue so
let's go question you've come quite a
long way to warmer Hampton into our
offices and also to talk and help some
advanced students why do you come all
this way in order to help support what
we're doing with the with the training
within our company and I love helping
people I spend most of my day on the
phone helping people I probably help
more people than we can do legal work in
their office and part of helping people
is helping people progress I've done
quite well in property I'm quite happy
other people can benefit from experience
but I also take a lot of pride in
getting good employment for people in
the area that I live and so we've had
we've got three trainees I've just had
to get rid of a trainee unfortunately
we're immediately recruiting another
trainee as soon as another trainee
qualifies or expecting to qualify in the
autumn I'll be getting another trainee
in to replace them and we've been
struggling to grow our legal practice
through through and bringing people in
with a qualified because we simply can't
get hold of right yeah we certainly get
all the right caliber of people people
the right attitude and so we're getting
people in with the right attitude and
training them it's a very long-term
strategy but we've just got to keep keep
keep putting people in I love that final
words of advice set your goal reassess
you go is it
check the gold talk to mentor about the
gold is it the right goal for you when
you've got a goal go for it love that
don't give up
well Sam we've got a bunch of people
waiting for us looking forward to
hearing from you and picking your brain
so let's smash it thank you so much for
your time
thank you thank you so much for watching
if you benefited from that video please
do share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here
and if you'd like to spend two days with
me at the property investors crash
course watch this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time